[Music]
I think now is a great time to tell
stories like this because people are so
interested in the stories of real people
and these are real people who
unfortunately aren't around to tell
their stories anymore so I think now is
the perfect time there was something
about the Playboy brand that had a
little bit more of a Mystique to it be a
playmate it's a ticket to the highlight
it was Fantasyland we were like rock
stars what can you tease about what we
are going to see with this project well
the Playboy murders is a six-part series
and each part is about a different
murder that somehow involves someone
within the Playboy World whether it was
a playmate or a bunny all the stories
are completely different many of them
haven't been covered publicly at all
they were stories that I hadn't even
heard of and I thought I knew everything
about Playboy history and what happened
to all the Playmates so I was really
intrigued when I first heard about this
idea I remember her saying that all the
Glitters isn't gold not everybody is who
they say they are when pose new a lot of
people seem to think it grants them some
kind of ownership of you when you first
started hearing of these stories how did
that hit you emotionally at any point
were you like this could have been my
life this could have happened to me I
feel very emotionally connected to these
stories and I think a lot of other
people will too because this kind of
thing could really happen to anyone you
know there's so many stories that happen
within relationships or from stalkers
and things like that stalkers who had
like inappropriate access to people they
should add access to and this kind of
thing could really happen to anybody and
I think that's what makes these stories
so compelling
only E.T was behind the scenes in Las
Vegas with former Playmate and the girls
next door star Holly Madison for the
true crime series The Playboy murders
premiering on ID and Discovery plus
January 23rd I love the way it looks the
lighting is so good so in addition to
Executive producing you'll also be
starring in it what role will you be
serving in the actual series I'm telling
a lot of the back story about the
Playboy world and what was going on in
the business at the time and what a lot
of these women were doing when they
worked for the company as someone who
knows this yeah very well wow
cross-border Manhunt is underway tonight
now the first episode your Premiere
episode
sounds very intense what can fans expect
right out of the gate with this project
with that episode one oh there's one
story in particular about a woman who is
from Las Vegas and that one was
particularly compelling and touching to
me because this was someone who was in
The Playboy world right after I was like
I narrowly missed meeting her and she
had so many of the same hopes and dreams
that I did one of my close friends
actually knew her because they used to
go to the same pool parties and things
and hearing about the murder and what
happened to her which was so incredibly
brutal and something that happened
within you know what she felt was a
loving relationship is just really
horrifying no one who loved a human
being would do this she was beaten that
fast the killer thought that they had
done everything they needed to do to
conceal the death and or the identity of
the person they killed
they forgot one item she was identified
by the serial number on her breast
implants which just goes to show how
brutally he handled her
you obviously knew Hugh Hefner very well
what would he make of these stories
coming to light now in this project I
mean I think he'd want them to be told
too you know these were real people some
of whom worked for him and they deserve
justice and they deserve to have their
stories told what do you think it is
about this billion dollar brand that
seems to be so heavily attached to
danger and lead to dangerous outcomes
like that well I think just a brand
being in business for over 50 years and
having so many people being involved
with the brand and also people perceive
sexuality as a dangerous thing sometimes
and it can lead to a lot of Blurred
Lines sometimes unfortunately but really
these stories are things that could
happen to anybody like you don't have to
be a playmate or a woman putting
yourself out there and I think these
stories will be surprisingly relatable
and compelling to so many people
what would you say is the darkest thing
that you experienced in your time
associated with the brand
I think for me it was just being in a
relationship that was emotionally
abusive and not being mature enough to
really understand the Dynamics of that
so for me it got pretty dark personally
which is quite different from a lot of
the stories we're going to be exploring
in this show but in a way you know it
makes me feel a kinship with these women
as well
I feel like things can be very dangerous
with social media do you ever think
about that with the Playmates now I
think things can be so dangerous for
anyone on social media I always say you
know as a mom I don't show like my kids
faces anymore and I always say to people
like if that feels right to you fine but
even if you're not in the public eye
like maybe create a private account like
be really careful about what you post
try not to post think where you are in
real time I think even if you're not in
the public eye or anything like that
everybody should be really careful
for you what is the why is it because
it's not safe to have their image out
there is there more to it as well yeah
there's definitely more to it like I
don't like putting my kids images out
there not only for their safety and
their security but also I just don't
want the negative energy of like people
commenting on different things or like
their opinions weighing in I don't like
it that that affects my life at all and
I would like to just keep that out of
their world even if they're not aware of
it I just don't like that energy
do you still experience people having
these preconceived notions I know you
mentioned it before but do people still
have these preconceived notions about
your past and past association with the
Playboy brand that affects you today
yeah I mean people still have all kinds
of preconceived notions about me or my
background or what I should be speaking
about or what I shouldn't be speaking
about and that's why I do continue to
talk about all these things as I kind of
feel like I was put on this Earth to
show people that there's Nuance to a
story and that not everything is black
and white yeah so that's what I like to
keep talking about does that affect your
dating life at all like these
preconceived notions like how do you
separate it I've been um
before I've had periods of time where
I've been single and it did affect my
dating life like people had all kinds of
preconceived notions or they really want
to date me but they wouldn't want to be
serious because the whole Playboy thing
but I have a boyfriend now who's like
super secure and like none of that stuff
bothers him and he just knows me for me
so I'm really lucky would you say this
is like your favorite chapter yet of
life being a mother being in a
relationship like you and now serving as
an executive producer on this amazing
project I love seeing
where life has taken yeah thanks no I do
feel like this is the best time in my
life ever the only thing I would wish
for is just like more time because you
want all the time with your kids and you
want to enjoy all your career things and
your relationship time so but I'm
blessed to be able to complain about
that I guess
you are booked in busy this project and
of course now your Memoir turning also
into a project I mean hey this is this
has got to be really exciting for you
it's a really exciting time yeah down
the rabbit hole being turned into the
television miniseries what can we expect
there because turning a memoir into TV
can be tricky sometimes I'm so excited
about this project because I love the
production team I love the director they
chose Samara weaving is going to be
playing me so I'm so excited and it's
taking a long time to happen and they're
always like thank you for your patience
thank you I'm like no because I want to
be made it I'd rather it be made right
than be me quickly for sure I'm so
excited and I love everything the
directors put together all her mood
boards and I'm so excited about it I'm
so happy to see where life has taken you
and it sounds like there's going to be a
lot more good things to come and
congratulations on this series and again
thanks for letting E.T hang out with you
thank you
foreign